welcome to this video Glen masazuka told
you but no name let's see what he's
doing there we get the news oh yeah I
can almost be sure that they don't go
for the Queens gambit but it's not a bad
wouldn't be a bad choice even d500 free
yeah b6 slyness gained in popularity as
a form c5 is some surprisingly i'm
surprisingly good for black so I'm just
transposing to this kind of this kind of
setup 94 it's a bit early actually I
mean okay it's it's playable yeah that's
not a bad move but kind of early yeah
white has the basic choice of PN
chattering or playing with III a
Memphian shadowing normally you need a
bishop on you for this this kind of
structure it's um the more yeah how can
you say the bishop only form is the most
sophisticated setup that control its d5
even more here I sometimes might get in
d5 I am interesting way to play knight
c6 ok I have to castle anyway so what
give five now is possible is it good hmm
at least after d5 you probably cannot
take it as c7 is hanging and drinking
also ok let's let's play it I'm going to
play it anyway so might as well do it
quicker so 97 is what he has to do
and now that's an interesting moment do
I need to really care about d5 hanging
probably I do so let's take be sure to
f4 I have two should be five smell maybe
he's simply giving up c7 that's possible
night-night g6 for example that could be
a cookie nidm just give away c7 ya know
now I have seen it bit late now g5
though that would have been an idea in
any way 95 90 x 25 / should be some this
night age three okay I mean if I take it
what does this come to play with b5
problem if he takes politics I have 95
you might play if I've come himself well
then I drop back yeah oh not so easy not
so used to this position types have to
really think for a moment where to where
to put stuff and going back this is what
I wanted to do that I have the rookin
plane and then i can safely drop back
after this yeah i was actually thinking
he has to do something about 95 but it
seems that he's not agreeing why is he
just going 96
I don't know maybe he can just know 96 I
take with the rook and heroes I was
thinking that g5 is a it's something
they are here well before leading
nowhere I guess don't take it you see
fiber move for this c-54 Quincy for iOS
is ridiculous and not entirely i have a
check then I can click on the aid c5
roop t1 maybe do you want to do one
night then the chick that's not
altogether convincing yeah anyway I have
to play it at some point c4 c5 for
Quincy for check it's the most active
move so even if it is not winning or
tactically and so convincing it's still
probably best because it activates
enormously with Quincy for coming
whoopty one rookie 195 Quincy for
checking a jade there is there is no
winning tactic that I see looks kind of
dangerous but I still don't see a
winning tactic a threat in quincy for
winning I think with my almost with rook
da 1097 but yeah interesting to see what
he's doing him
okay so he wants to keep track check
check first think later and so I can
take here and you will take with the
night then then I drop back which
doesn't need too much night is six let's
kind of a self pen but ok anyway so now
it takes I can take b6 actually for the
taking c 70 I need to switch off the
phone I already do before I start to
play yeah okay that all netted to me not
much but maybe I get a loop t1 so I have
the more I'm i have the more effective
control over those open lines
yeah I know that that's a really good
good piece 925 he's going to play Knight
f7 what exactly is my move against that
I was a silly silly way to play probably
time morning yeah should have come to
some some other square knot not quite
sure which one but this is not not doing
me much good
yeah not sure I should I can't even take
with the pawn I'm not not sure about
that not going that all so sb2 is not
hanging anymore i'm going to trade him
check like 94 known I'd reform
91 check it's not exactly difficult yeah
yeah yeah I've got 95 if I should have
played 97 at least check don't worry
don't really don't really understand his
play here rapid and now I'm better here
in this end game all of a son poops
mostly
Jack Black for kids on time yeah how how
it was possible that i won the game it's
not really clear to me it was it was a
completely lost a night end game and a
really bad game overall yeah I mean
around here it's equal ish but really
find something great I thought this
should be actually quite nice for me but
somehow it didn't it didn't did
materialize somewhere around here maybe
96 mmm Jim but it's not leading to much
it it's probably just about equal this
this kind of this kind of thing yeah I
playing at this is this is just a stupid
move young just very stupid he plays
night the night and then whoop dat is
the threat so it's just us just um kind
of useless to do the I should should go
here maybe a voice even better here so
that I attack at the moment I actually
after somewhat more active position and
this should um at least mean that I'm
comfortable I shouldn't be in trouble
and after this I'm just stepping into
this into this route da thing yeah 96 is
probably not not very useful in addition
yeah that's not that's not really really
good here O'Rouke c7 is still about
equal yeah maybe yeah but um yeah I
stumbled into this night c4 was what I
had expected and this is this is ok
quindi 7 seems to her word for for
surprisingly why exactly night h5 or
what is the point 96 the idea being
Queen e8 night of ATR the computer is
obviously very strong him
okay I didn't see any of that yet here
I'm just stumbling into a totally lost
and get a check which somehow he did not
win I don't I don't really know around
yet it's not it's not completely trivial
yeah he idea CNIB five just wins the
porn but turned here we are getting into
territory where this chess is becoming
somewhat difficult check yeah still it
was surprising that he just took them
and went into the key and porn end game
which really is a complete win yeah not
the best game ever ok I hope you enjoyed
it nevertheless thanks for watching